la crise ukrainienne et ses conséquences
économiques pour la russie mais
également pour l'europe alors que les
initiatives diplomatiques se multiplient
certaines voix l'ouest demandent des
sanctions contre moscou le gaz mais
aussi le pétrole russe sont visés alors
l'union européenne peut-elle se passer
de la russie sur le plan énergétique y
at il vraiment une alternative au gaz
russe on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir et c'est
l'heure de l'édito échos
bonsoir jacques quelques petite
pirouette sur ce plateau ce soir on vous
a vu arriver mais voilà c'est joies du
direct bonsoir jacques en tout cas alors
on parle beaucoup évidemment de
sanctionner la russie en cessant de lui
acheter du gaz finalement est-ce que
c'est crédible non en fait très peu
l'union européenne a besoin de gaz l1
aura besoin encore plus dans les dix
années qui viennent si on veut justement
cesser de consommer du charbon de la
tour de la ligne bat tous ces carburants
qui sont terriblement polluants alors
après ce qu'il faut dire c'est que si on
va consommer du gaz leur va consommer du
gaz par gazoduc du gnl et là on voit que
les capacités de transformation du gnl
en gaz utilisables sont d'ores et déjà
saturé donc ce qui fait que en réalité
il y a très peu d'alternatives au gaz
russe alors commençons par regarder la
balance énergétique de l'union
européenne qu'on est il de la dépendance
au gaz et donc au gaz russe alors
globalement l'union européenne dépend à
plus de 58% des hydrocarbures pétrole et
gaz si on rajoute évidemment les
carburants solides donc charbon lignite
tourbe ça rajoute 11% au montât
pratiquement 70% là dessus 23% c'est du
gaz alors ce que l'on peut penser c'est
que justement donc que dans les années
qui viennent et bien cette part va
augmenter alors une partie de la
consommation de charbon et de l'inite
sera prise en charge par les énergies
vertes les énergies renouvelables mais
une autre partie sera en tous les cas
pour les 10 ans qui viennent sera
reprise par le gaz et donc ça veut dire
que la consommation globale de gaz
pourraient atteindre 28 à 29 % à
l'horizon de 2030 et quelle est la part
en provenance de la russie alors la laci
voulait on va parler maintenant des
importations sur la question des
importations il faut d'abord savoir que
l'union européenne importe beaucoup de
choses de la russie du pétrole du
charbon aussi aussi étonnant que cela
puisse paraître est évidemment du gaz
alors elle importe grosso modo 43% de
son charbon de russie
26-27 % du pétrole et 34 % du gaz donc
ça veut dire que le gaz russe représente
un peu plus du tiers des importations
européennes après ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que il ya toute une
série de fournisseur historique de
l'union européenne par exemple la
norvège la grande-bretagne
les pays-bas rossi dont la part a
beaucoup diminué depuis une dizaine
d'années tout simplement parce que les
gisements sont en train de s'épuiser
alors il ya d'autres fournisseurs qui
sont apparus sur le marché il ya les
états unis il ya le qatar
ça c'est du gnl parce que si on veut
transporter du gaz des états unis ou du
qatar va pas tirer un gazoduc donc il
faut le faire en gnl et puisque l'on
voit surtout sur le graphique là c'est
que la part de la russie elle elle a
continué à monter en 2009 la part de la
russie s'était 27 % aujourd'hui ses 34%
alors qu'en est il du rapport entre le
gnl et le gaz des gazoducs alors voilà
justement quand on parle de garde
évidemment dans l'imaginaire
globalement oui les gros gazoduc le
gazoduc qui passait par l'ukraine etc
mais en fait on a maintenant depuis
assez longtemps du gaz naturel liquéfié
pour donner le nom complet est alors ce
gaz naturel liquéfié ils venaient
d'algérie il venait il vient d'ailleurs
toujours du nigeria il vient des états
unis qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que au départ vous avez des
stations qui comprime le gaz les grosses
industries l'un des grosses en fait
infrastructures industrielles y compris
le gaz le gaz deviennent league id sous
forte pression donc il peut être
transporté par bateau mais après il faut
le délicat fier il faut leur transformé
en gaz gazeuse alors là on voit qu'il y
a toute une série de stations de
regazéification on le voit à l'écran il
y en a quatre en france deux à fos une à
montoir-de-bretagne une à dunkerque il
ya un global mans 20 dans l'union
européenne trois en grande bretagne mais
ces stations travaille déjà à plein
rendement on ne peut pas faire venir
plus de gaz naturel liquéfié tout
simplement parce qu'on n'arriverait pas
à le re gazéifiée alors ça veut dire en
gros que vous pensez finalement vrai que
ces menaces sur les importations russes
relève plus de la gesticulation que de
la réalité oui globalement oui si vous
voulez quand on voit par exemple
l'ampleur des importations bon les
importations en gaz de russie c'est à
peu près pour 31 milliards d'euros
les importations en gnl c'est au tour de
11 milliards d'euros si on veut stopper
complètement les importations de russie
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait rajouter ou
11 milliards d'euros de gnl les 30
milliards d'euros du gaz russe sauf que
comme le gnl coûte plus cher que le gars
normal ça voudrait dire non pas 30
milliards c'est vrai 40 milliards de
plus autrement dit il faudrait quintuplé
les capacités de regazéification et là
on voit bien c'est pas possible c'est
absolument pas possible à court terme ça
peut se faire dans un délai de sept à
dix ans mais ça coûtera très cher et ça
demandera énormément d'investissement ça
veut dire que ces menaces un dont on
entend parler ces derniers jours de ce
pc du gaz russe ont en quelque sorte des
paroles en l'air oui largement largement
alors d'abord du côté des fournisseurs
il faut d'abord savoir que les
fournisseurs actuels eh bien ils sont
pratiquement saturé les etats-unis ne
sont pas dans l'immédiat capable de
fournir du gnl supplémentaires le qatar
assez peu parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que le qatar c'est l'un des principaux
approuvé fin disons fournisseur du japon
et le japon lui n'utilise que du gnl bon
donc on voit déjà que là c'est un petit
peu bloquée et puis il ya une question
dont personne ne parle les capacités de
production du gaz russe elles ne sont
pas infinies or aujourd'hui la russie
préfère vendre du gaz dans des contrats
à long terme à des pays d'asie que ce
soit la chine bien entendu mais aussi la
corée du sud mais aussi l'un et donc
d'une certaine manière c'est pas la
question que l'on peut se poser ce n'est
pas si l'europe va décider un jour de
non on ne veut plus du tout de gaz russe
mais plus et il est heureusement débat
écoutez vous ne voulez pas nous nous
nous acheter du gaz dans le cadre de
contrats de long terme eh bien on va
aller le vendre aux pays asiatiques et
on se retrouvera fort dépourvue quand la
bise sera venue merci beaucoup jacques
sapir pour cet édito et ce décryptage
merci à vous